Chad hrim had the perfect response to
Nicole yic after the Joker commented on
Chad's size after Sunday's game against
the nuggets and thunder yic was asked
about playing Chad he started off by of
course praising Chad but then he offered
some advice he said one Chad needs
experience and two and I quote needs to
be a little fatter to be honest chat
later responded in a postgame interview
a few days later saying it's hard to get
fatter when you're not fat so I got to
start somewhere I guess talking about
Chad's weight isn't anything new and
people have been worried about him
staying on his own two feet when going
up against players like yic Giannis and
embiid but he's still standing and he's
holding his own and he's still
impressing everyone this season